you're kidding yourself if you think
cutting taxes today is really cutting
taxes we're simply deferring massive tax
increases into the future unfairly and
immoral II putting huge debt burdens on
future generations i am nick gillespie
with reason TV today we're talking with
david stockman a former congressman who
is best remembered as the budget
director for ronald reagan david thanks
for talking with us good to be here
you're back in the spotlight and getting
roasted again by your fellow Republicans
because you've been an outspoken
advocate of letting all of the bush-era
tax rates expire what's your rationale
behind that well philosophically we
should have as low taxes as lower taxes
as we possibly can the problem is you're
kidding yourself if you think cutting
taxes today is really cutting taxes
we're simply deferring massive tax
increases into the future unfairly and
immorally putting huge debt burdens on
future generations there's a presumption
there that if we raised more federal
revenue that would go to pay what we're
what we're actually doing now as opposed
to just give the government more impetus
to grow even faster well that's always a
risk but I think the fact is there isn't
much pressure for structural expansion
of the budget right now those third need
to be though because I mean Medicare
spending set to continue to expand
particularly after 2020 I mean so there
doesn't need to be a politician saying
let's raise let's create whole new
entitlements because we've got ones that
are on autopilot to explode right oh yes
I mean in addition to allowing the tax
cuts to expire we need to means test
radically the retirement entitlements
let's talk a little bit about your kind
of political philosophy and economic
philosophy you came into the Reagan
administration and you worked long and
hard on coming up with the way to cut
taxes right right what to break and cut
the top tax rates from all right the top
tax rate on earned income was fifty
percent of the time and I
we ended up in the low 40s but what
happened subsequently was almost no
spending was cut and the defense budget
sword out of control we knew going in
that there was a commitment by President
Reagan to rebuild defense capability but
what happened in the early days was that
the Pentagon distorted campaign promises
for real growth of five percent which
they then raised a seven percent and
Reagan went along and then they started
it from a much higher base which is to
say a supplemental bill and as a result
of that defense spending got totally out
of control between 81 and 85 basically
the Reagan administration doubled the
national debt what would you have done
differently knowing knowing how things
played out well I think you would really
have to sit down and make some very
large and honest conclusions and that is
what is the welfare state that we're
going to keep because we don't have the
political will to change it or we
believe it is necessary how much defense
do we really want let's lay it out let's
justify it and if that's twenty-four
percent of GDP or twenty percent of GDP
then what is the optimum tax system that
will raise twenty percent or twenty-four
percent as the case may be the last
honest war president we had was Truman
surprisingly and when the Vietnam or the
Korean War budget ballooned he demanded
the Congress institute major tax
increases excise taxes income taxes to
pay for the war on a pay-as-you-go basis
is the triumph of politics that we don't
even get to have those conversations or
that we'll have them but then we don't
really stick ourselves to it we don't
keep to a budget well first I think we
need to have the conversations but then
we need to recognize the underlying
demographic context of what the steady
state claim on GDP is and the whole
entitlement structure retirement
entitled Social Security Medicare it's a
intergenerational Ponzi scheme the baby
boom is now inexorably moving towards
retirement
beyond and so therefore the share of GDP
that it's consuming continues to rise
the current generation of workers are
going to be turned into tax slaves just
like the workers in Ireland today are
finding out that they are and that will
have to change but it will only change
when the crisis comes now in the new
york times over the summer you laid one
of the four deformations of the fiscal
apocalypse on the heads of pointless
speculation and stocks bonds commodities
and derivatives are you arguing that
essentially that these this trade only
existed because of regulations or of a
government system or a political economy
where people knew if they were playing
around with that kind of stuff that they
would get bailed out well I think it
goes beyond or further back than that I
think it goes to the closing of the gold
window in 1971 it goes to the and that
because the last shred of anchoring the
u.s. dollar to a gold standard yes and
because that system as it had his
defects Bretton Woods but at the heart
of it was a fixed exchange rate system
and an obligation on each company in
country including the United States to
settle its accounts at the end of every
year and if you began to run chronic
payments deficits you were going to
under that system lose your monetary
reserves now when we got rid of all of
that and went to pure fiat money it
began a process in which financial
volatility and instability reached what
had been previously unimaginable levels
and so if you have exchange rates
careening all over the place if you have
interest rates soaring and then
declining and then bouncing to and fro
the market will invent hedges so I think
much of this mass
you know 700 trillion derivatives market
which is out there was fostered by the
breakdown of fixed exchange rates in the
anchor of the monetary system to a asset
gold in that case that couldn't be
manipulated for short-term purposes by
governments in central banks do you I
mean do you see anybody in the political
arena who is you know who gives you hope
or who seems to get what you're talking
about I think the heart of the problem
is our monetary system is out of control
there's only one guy who understands it
it's ron paul right well as anyone else
when he's newly ascended in terms of
power right that's true and I mean so
what do you think that that will be the
beginning or could that be the beginning
well I think maybe it will begin to
disinfect the process maybe it will
begin to shed some light on all the
pretensions and the scholastic arrogance
of the Fed feds economist and the
Federal Reserve itself and that maybe is
at least a small step towards beginning
to address the real problems in this
country well David Stockman thank you
very much for a really interesting
conversation thank you
you
you're kidding yourself if you think
cutting taxes today is really cutting
taxes we're simply deferring massive tax
increases into the future
immorally putting huge debt burdens on
future generations